Check out this trade right here. I am up
over $4,000. And what's crazy is this
trade was confirmed by something almost
nobody pays attention to. It's not an
indicator, it's not some magic pattern.
It's a clue inside the candlestick that
tells you when momentum is actually
shifting. Once you learn this, your
entries get cleaner, your stops get
tighter, and you stop taking those
trades that look perfect but instantly
reverse on you. So, in this video, I'm
going to show you exactly what I'm
looking for, how I trade it in real
time, and I'll also show you the fake
out versions. So, you know what is real
versus a fake signal. Okay, so this
right here is the candlestick that
confirmed the trade entry. And if you're
thinking, "That's just a big green
candlestick, whatever, right? Obviously,
that means the market's more likely to
go up." That's exactly the trap because
minutes before, there was a big bullish
candlestick, they actually turned into a
trap where the market reversed on it.
What most people do is they only study
what the candlestick looks like after it
closes. But how and where it forms can
tell you a completely different story.
And this is the part that will level up
your trading. A candlestick can finish
looking super bullish, but it can form
in a way that shows you it's fake. And
that's how traders get baited into
horrible entries. So, I'm going to show
you three versions of the same
candlestick, and I'm telling you they
don't all tell you the same exact story.
So, here are three candlesticks that,
when they're closed, look exactly the
same. Now, this can work on a 1-minute
chart, 5-minute, any type of chart, a
daily chart. The key is to realize that
even though the candlesticks close like
this, how it's formed can completely
change what it tells you. And so, first
example is this. Could form while you
watch the candlestick form, the market
could start here and slowly trend higher
with little pullbacks in the middle.
That is a healthy trend. And so, this is
a really good case to show that, hey,
yeah, the market's been really bullish
in this candlestick, most likely it's a
strong signal. Now, the next example is
where the market opens up, moves up, has
a pullback in the middle of it, and then
pushes higher. In this case, this is
also a healthy example because the
market's had time to pull back in this
candlestick. Now, the third option is
where the market just shoots straight
up. This is where a trap can happen
because this is an unhealthy move that
the market does. No matter what time
frame you're in, even if you're in a
1-minute chart, if the market moves
straight up with no pullbacks, even over
60 seconds, it's not going to be
healthy, and it's likely to give it back
up. And we'll go into situations
because it's not just about reading the
specific candle, it's about seeing these
in certain areas in the market, and
they'll help you key into what's the
potential outcome. Okay, so watch this
candlestick form right here. It opens
here pretty much, chops for a little
bit, and then just shoots higher. And
so, what that does and tells me is it's
made a spike higher that in a choppy
environment is more likely to instantly
get reversed the next candlestick. And
so, this is something that you can read
into during when you're watching the
market. Even if you see a big bullish
candlestick or even a big bearish
candlestick. Here, this candlestick does
a huge move lower. And so, you know, I
used to think that, oh, wow, huge move
lower and it closes basically as a huge
big bearish candlestick where, you know,
opened here and closed here at the lows.
In candlestick theory, that would be a
huge bearish signal. But, because it
happened in an unhealthy way, in a
market where it's just choppy, again
looking at that kind of more bigger
picture and trend that the market's in,
you can see the next candlestick just
immediately reverses it. And so, this is
where you want to be not just blindly
looking at the candlesticks. You want to
be reading what they're telling you in
relation to the larger picture. And so,
even when the market breaks out here and
breaks out of this kind of range, it
gives that back up because it's in a
choppy mode. But, if you can read into
this, there's a couple signals here that
tell you it's starting to shift. One is
okay, this is a big red candlestick. You
can see that seems like a huge signal to
potentially go lower, correct? But, if
this candlestick gets reversed, the way
I read that as well, this was an
unhealthy move that immediately reversed
and in the bigger picture context of
things, looking at okay, we have a
downtrend and now it's starting to make
higher highs and higher lows, it has a
potential to go higher. And so, this is
where I see as a strong candlestick,
this big green candlestick tells me,
even though it formed very quickly, if
we actually zoom back here a little, you
can see that it has little pullbacks as
it moves higher. And so, that also tells
me that it's got a little bit of a
strength in it. And as well, giving back
this unhealthy move previously this
candlestick, that is part of a larger
pattern playing out. And so, that's how
I confirm entering my trades is when
patterns and the candlesticks show you
that they're actually following through
versus, you know, having that potential
follow through being an area that
doesn't make sense. So, check out this
trade right here. This is the trade I
previously took, and I'm looking for a
head and shoulders pattern here and a
break above this highs. Look at how this
candlestick forms. It comes up and it
pulls back mid candlestick showing that
healthy pullback, and then it pushes
higher and actually breaks this high.
And so, I look to jump in as it breaks
that high, and then it actually even
pulls back a little bit and fills me.
And so, that's a big bullish
candlestick, and but because it has
these pullbacks in it, it shows more
strength. And that combined with this
bottom down here that it put in of a
higher low, it helps confirm that the
bigger picture is happening and I can
look for a larger move to play out.
That's how reading into the candlesticks
really plays out, and then I put my
stop-loss below that big candlestick
because it's a good confirmation and it
shows strength. When these big
candlesticks have strength behind them,
they're more likely to hold because the
market has had a strong move in that
direction and it's been a strong healthy
move in an area that makes sense for it
to have that kind of move. Going back to
the previous example, where before I
entered the trade, the market was having
big candlesticks in either direction,
but there was no bigger picture behind
them. Now, another way to avoid
potential traps is here we have an
example from actually a couple days ago
in the market where the Nasdaq here
pushed higher and then started to sell
off. And so, this right here was an
unhealthy bullish candlestick, where the
market just shot up and then it gave
that whole candlestick and some back up.
And so, this can be a good signal of a
topping pattern. But, in this case, you
don't want to just short when you see
this pattern alone. You want to wait for
something like this to happen, of the
market to make another attempt to go
higher and then reverse. And this
candlestick does a great job of showing
you that because it opened up here,
pushed higher, and reversed. And so, if
you play this out with that in mind, the
candlesticks, the price has basically
put in a double top here. But, just
using this candlestick alone and jumping
in on a short here to bet the market's
going to go down would lose you money
because you're not confirming that it's
making a lower high. You would have to
wait for it to break this low here
before betting that it went down.
Because otherwise, in this case, this
can happen, where it came here, pushed
higher, pulled back, and instead
actually made a double bottom after it
made a double top. And the reason why
this happens is because it comes up to
an area where it's likely to find some
resistance, but this trend is strong
enough to where it, you know, just takes
a second to regain some strength and
then break through that. And so, that's
why you need to be with your candlestick
patterns is take into account the big
picture. And so, I've created a PDF that
has my favorite candlestick patterns in
it that will talk about the theory and
the reality behind them and what's
actually important to this pattern and
what's actually unimportant factors that
trip people up and they think are
important about. And so, I highly
recommend getting this. You can get it
in this description of this video or the
this QR code. And so, if you want a
deeper dive into how I read the bigger
picture trends and understand the whole
overall market and what the likely
direction of it is, check out this video
right here. It'll go into in-depth
details and signals that have taken me
years to understand.